the Elvis voice was still very present
in your voice I think there's a lot less
of it now and maybe sometimes I have a
southern twang but I'm not I don't think
this is Southern if I tried to sound
like Elvis I would sound very different
right now don't do it yeah
but the other thing is I think I from
all the singing I I probably have
destroyed my voice a bit you know my
vocal questions it's a lot raspier now I
try to stop social media so my publicist
told me you know people are talking
about your voice and these sorts of
things and it really made me
self-conscious for a second because I
thought am I being phony is this not my
voice and
um and and then I thought oh I'd have to
think consciously to not talk how I am
right now have you gone to a speech
therapist or anything
what did you sound like before yeah
people who pull clips from when I was
17.